[Musique]
aux précédents livres ont été traduits
dans plusieurs langues il avait remporté
de nombreux prix
alors pourquoi avoir attendu neuf ans
entre votre nouveau au lien familial et
celui d'avant mais j'ai beaucoup écrit
pendant neuf ans quand j'ai jamais
autant écrit mais c'était pour la télé
puis le cinéma donc j'ai pris beaucoup
de temps sur des projets en thérapie
j'étais aussi j'ai des français placent
au cours de mes actrices comme deuxième
auteur et je suis tombé tard elle à
devenir la vache ça a pris beaucoup de
mon temps j'ai eu ma fille aussi ce qui
est ce qui m'a dit si le quotidien
depuis le temps qu'on peut consacrer à
un projet personnel change conclure je
tout est plus simple qui dit quoi
capacité d'être un public l'avait
mentionné vous avez écrit l'adaptation
québécoise de l'émission en thérapie est
ce que c'est un choix artistique ou son
choix financiers j'aime beaucoup écrire
pour l'intelligence je regarde beaucoup
la télé j'aime beaucoup les séries télé
qui sont bien bien entendu mais donc
j'en consomme coup puis c'est vraiment
par plaisir c'est sûr que ça paye mieux
qu écrire des livres sont se cache repos
mais c'est vraiment pas juste un
gagne-pain pour moi j'apprends beaucoup
en écrivant pour la télé c'est un type
d'écriture qui il pas structuré donc
j'adore ça votre dernier roman un lien
familial
parle beaucoup d'adultère de séparation
de tromperie et ça c'est un thème qui
est récurrent depuis 1999 depuis votre
premier recueil de nouvelles
pourquoi nadine bismuth vous intéresser
autant à la tromperie dans un couple
mois l'infidélité c'est pas juste
anecdotique c'est un vrai drame ça
relève pas juste du vaudeville c'est une
vraie blessure que quel que les gens
vivent quand ils sont dans des
situations d'infidélité des gros
déchirement c'est une humiliation aussi
et puis ce qui m'intéresse là dedans
puis je pense pourquoi je reviens
toujours c'est parce que c'est un thème
qui est vraiment classique c'est-à-dire
la société a traversé tellement de
révolution culturelle sexuelle il ya
plus de modèles c'est un éclatement on
peut vivre notre vie comme on veut mais
l'infidélité reste une transgression
ça reste dans l'interdît c'est donc pour
moi ça c'est intéressant d'aller
toujours creuser là dedans pis pour la
première fois j'aborde le thème quand il
ya des enfants dans portrait fils a
ajouté beaucoup de contraintes puis des
déchirures des déchirements en disant
votre dernier livre on a l'impression
que c'est difficile être mère en 2018
est ce que c'est votre impression je
pense que oui puis vraiment le son on ne
prépare pas bien à toutes les tous les
sacrifices que ça peut demander à être
mère comment ça change notre rapport aux
hommes si beaucoup comment ça change
notre rapport à notre travail c'est
quelque chose d'autre comme moi je t'ai
pas préparé à ça
puis on est débordé je parle dans le
livre les filles sont débordés ici la
narratrice puis les autres pays mais on
est débordé je regarde autour de moi
puis les weight on est tout le temps en
train de faire des listes de ce qu'il
faut faire
quel rendez vous il faut prendre puis
dans le roman fait il ya cette espèce
d'asservissement des femmes à une espèce
de modèles perfection en tant que
féministe j'ai l'impression qu'il reste
encore beaucoup de travail avant
d'atteindre l'égalité en forme êtes-vous
d'accord nous sommes vraiment vraiment
pigeonnier en même temps j'ai pas de
solution je trouve que ça donne dans la
cellule du couple je trouve que vraiment
des inégalités qui peuvent surgir si
t'as pas mis certaines choses au clair
avec ton conjoint avant d'avoir des
enfants sur l'organisation sur du
quotidien il ne serait ce que du
quotidien c'est pour moi la cellule du
couple ça fait autant être un refuge un
cocon un lieu de bien-être
mais ça peut autant être un lieu de
d'une qualité des luttes de pouvoir puis
dans mes romans dans mes histoires moi
j'aime ce jeu romancière fait que j'aime
le conflit mois les personnages qui me
viennent à l'esprit sur lesquels j'ai
envie d'écrire mais c'est les
personnages pour qui ça va mal
donc ça mais c'est pour ça que le couple
et pas des ports aux dans ce que j'écris
j'ai tendance à vouloir exploiter le
côté sombre des dunes bismuth vous avez
cinq projets et leur développement avec
pas j'en ai un autre avec animaux cie
qui est une série d'époque
ça serait vraiment vraiment une belle
belle série
qu'on va commencer à écrire cet hiver
donc oui le double